hello my name's David I'm 17 I'm
studying physics available I was just
wondering if there are parallel worlds
what would happen if we travel to it
with a funding at the same time I David
you're asking about parallel worlds well
there are two meanings of parallel
worlds in science one would be that
there are many other universes
paralleling ours maybe with separate
origins and maybe there's an infinite
number of such parallel universes in
that case we have no idea whether we
could get there from here
probably never that would be the first
guess we have very little evidence or
ways of measuring the presence of such
parallel universes that are really
distinct on the other hand there's
another parallel universe meaning in
science which is that of quantum
mechanics and where we talk about the
probability waves for particles and and
particle behavior of wavelets so all of
these things are a little mysterious and
it's a whole other subject which I can't
really explain I find it very confusing
myself sorry